a satellite of mass lowercase m orbits
earth at a radius capital r and speed v
naught is shown below so this has mass
lowercase m an aerospace engineer
decides to launch a second satellite
that is double the mass into the same
orbit so the same orbit so this radius
is still going to be capital r and so
this
satellite the second satellite has a
mass of 2m
the mass of earth is m so this is earth
right here capital m what is the speed
lowercase v of the heavier satellite in
terms of v naught and speed you can use
the magnitude of velocity and so that's
why it's a lowercase v without a vector
symbol on it and so what we're trying to
figure out the magnitude of its velocity
in order to stay in orbit what is
lowercase v
going to be equal to so pause this video
and see if you can figure it out on your
own
all right so to tackle this remember the
whole reason why something stays in
orbit instead of just going in a
straight line through space is because
there is going to be a constant
magnitude centripetal acceleration
towards the center of earth it keeps
turning i guess you could say the
satellite in this circular path and
we've seen from other videos that the
magnitude of our centripetal
acceleration is going to be equal to the
magnitude of our velocity and i'll just
use this first satellite so the
magnitude of its velocity squared
divided by our radius which in this case
is a capital r
but what
determines our centripetal acceleration
well we can explore newton's law of
gravitation there so if we think about
the magnitude of the force of gravity
well that's going to be equal to
g which is the universal gravitational
constant times the product of the two
masses
that have the force between them so the
product of the mass of earth capital m
and the mass of this satellite i'll just
focus on this satellite for now
divided by
the distance between their center of
masses squared in this case that is r
capital r
squared
and if you wanted the centripetal
acceleration you would just divide force
divided by mass remember from newton's
second law we know that f is equal to
m a
and so if we're talking about
centripetal acceleration it's the force
of gravity that is causing it and so if
we want to solve for centripetal
acceleration you just divide both sides
of these
by m
and so our centripetal acceleration here
if you divide our force of gravity by
lowercase m by the mass of the satellite
our centripetal acceleration is going to
be the universal gravitational constant
times the mass of earth divided by the
radius squared
and so we could then take this and
substitute it back over here and solve
for the magnitude of our velocity so
what you're going to have is
the universal gravitational constant
times the mass of earth divided by the
radius squared is equal to
the magnitude of our velocity or the
speed squared divided by capital r
now you can multiply both sides by r and
i'll swap sides as well you're going to
get v naught squared is going to be
equal to capital g times capital m
over r or if you take the square root of
both sides you get v naught is equal to
the square root of the universal
gravitational constant times the mass of
earth divided by the distance between
the center of masses
now what's interesting here is we see
the speed we need in order to maintain
this orbit in no way is it a function of
the mass of the satellite i don't see a
lowercase m anywhere in this expression
on the right hand side
and since this is independent of the
mass of the thing that is in orbit if
you double the mass if you go from case
m to 2 times lower case m it does not
change the needed orbital speed and so
what is the speed v of the heavier
satellite in terms of v naught it's
going to be the same thing we could
write v is going to be equal to v naught
it doesn't matter what you do to the
mass here you're going to need the same
orbital speed